welcome to the tim ferriss show this is
your host tim
ferriss you may notice that this intro
is different
from my usual intro i'm not going to
give you the spiel on interviewing
world class performers because we aren't
going to do that
in this particular episode for me
personally this is the most important
podcast episode i've ever published
and i wasn't sure i was going to publish
it at all i recorded it
just to record it and that'll be obvious
in the audio this episode will describe
the most
life shaping certainly the most
difficult and
certainly the most transformative
journey of my 43 years on this planet
this is a journey i've never shared
publicly before and i haven't really
shared it privately either
to give you an idea most of my family
and closest friends know nothing about
it
so they will be hearing about this for
the first time as well
i believe this episode is relevant to
almost everyone although it might not
seem that way
at the surface level but let me explain
if you haven't experienced
trauma yourself you will meet people who
have certainly
and you may already know people who have
been affected including friends or
family members who simply haven't told
you
and i find it helpful to remember that
everyone is fighting a battle
you know nothing about please note
before we get any further that this
episode is not
suitable for children so
consider yourselves warned my dance
partner and safety net
in this conversation is my friend debbie
millman debbie on twitter at debbie
millman
has been named one of the most creative
people in business by fast company and
is the host of design
matters a great podcast one of the
world's longest running podcasts
she is also chair of the masters and
branding program at the school of visual
arts
editorial director of print magazine and
has worked on design strategy for some
of the world's largest
brands you would recognize all of them
but all of that is
not why i asked her if she'd join me i
asked debbie because she's a dear friend
she's an excellent interviewer and she's
been an incredible support
for me in the last few years including
some late night emergency phone calls
and things of that sort
last but not least she and i have
experienced similar trauma but have
taken two
very different paths to healing using
very
very different tools so you get a
two-for-one deal in this conversation
that's the intention
this conversation was [ __ ] hard for
me
very difficult and i could have deleted
some of the stammering and struggling
but i chose not to
because that would have been fakery and
i wanted to share the emotional struggle
in its full rawness this stuff isn't
always easy
it's rarely easy and it's often messy
but
it is possible to get to the other side
and that's
one of the morals of the story and why
i'm sharing this
so please listen to the whole thing as
the lessons tools and resources and so
on
that have helped us are scattered
throughout they're all over the place
including an especially dense
last 30 minutes just a few more notes
and we'll get right into it
but i think that these notes are
important first
to those who know me and might reach out
please
note that i expect to be completely
overwhelmed emotionally and otherwise
when this is published and i sincerely
ask for your understanding if i'm not
able to reply to any outreach
it'll be a really challenging week for
me and i expect it'll probably be a very
challenging month
so thanks for understanding second this
is
and we are a work in progress debbie and
i both reserve the right to change our
minds about how we think
and feel about everything third and this
is a very important disclaimer we are
not
therapists we are not doctors we don't
play them on the internet
so this is not intended as professional
or medical advice
in any capacity this is for
informational purposes only
it's just two people sharing their very
personal stories
and perspectives as debbie put it in
this episode and you'll hear this
quote i think it's really important for
people to understand that their path to
healing is very much their own path to
healing
in the same way that everybody has their
own path to love or success
or family few resources there are
episodes that i mentioned
in the conversation debbie's first
podcast with me you can find it tim dot
blog
forward slash debbie d-e-b-b-i-e
you can find my conversation with blake
mykoski tim.blog
forward slash blake and with jack
cornfield
team dot blog forward slash jack and
everything mentioned in this episode
and many more things many more things
that might help
are available all in one place we've
gathered everything at
tim dot blog forward slash trauma that's
tim.blog
trauma okay here we go
so debbie first of all you are the
sweetest of sweethearts thank you for
doing this with me i know that you've
been
a trusted companion for quite a long
time
with respect to many other things that
we'll be talking about
and it really means the world to me so
thank you oh
my my honor tim truly truly
so i i don't think i'm gonna
bury the lead as they say in journalism
with this conversation i'll
start with this statement and then we
can work around that
okay so the statement
is on the opening
is that i was routinely sexually abused
from
ages two to four that seems to be
accurate based on
conversations with my mom about the
timeline
by the son of a babysitter so if you
imagine sort of the
most disgusting repulsive activities
that
you might envision with that statement
that
is that is what happened and
i don't know if it was on a weekly basis
i don't know if it was multiple times a
week but it was
frequent over a period of of two years
and i want to speak to
why i'm recording this podcast
and discussing this with you
now i'll tackle the why with you first
and that is because you really inspired
me
when seemingly a hundred years ago on
my podcast after i noted before our
conversation
that you seldom spoke about your
childhood you opened up and spoke about
your
own your own abuse that you suffered
through
and it was such a courageous act and
helped so many people
and my intention has always been to talk
about this
chapter i'd say over the last five or
six years at least that's been my
intention
and i've wanted to put it into a book
that tracks my healing journey
effectively and i had a conversation
with my girlfriend
perhaps six months ago
and this was just as kovid
was beginning to set in so this is
probably early february mid-february as
global news and i had fears
around my mortality due to
respiratory issues comorbidities and i'd
also
done work and therapy that involved
asking the question prior to that
if you were to say die tomorrow what
would you regret having not said or not
done
alternatively if you knew you had a year
left in perfect health and then you
would die
a year from now exactly what would you
do in that year
and at the very top of the list was
talking about
this sexual abuse and my girlfriend made
an observation as we were talking about
plans for the book which was
if the book takes three years there may
be people who are no longer
around in three years through suicide or
natural causes who could benefit who
might benefit
from speaking about this openly so that
is why i decided to record this and as
we're recording this
i don't know if i'm going to release it
or when i will release it but to at
least have a record you know god forbid
something were to happen to me i would
really regret
not having spoken about this and the
intention is
hopefully to show that it is possible
to find some light actually incredible
amounts of light in the darkness
and that there are tools available that
really do
work and help and
you know debbie it's been a roller
coaster in the last
say 36 hours as i've been appreciating
the
the realness of having this conversation
with you
because old coping mechanisms have
started to crop up like i even last
night i was talking to my girlfriend and
about this and i started to dissociate
right like my mind
started to separate itself from my body
so that my body could withstand
whatever it needed to withstand and for
those people who don't know what that
means i mean it you can induce it with
something like ketamine
certainly i don't recommend that but
it's a dissociative anesthetic
and it's a very odd experience
to describe to someone who hasn't
experienced it thankfully most people
haven't but
it's almost like you your consciousness
the locus of your awareness moves
outside your body so that you're not
subject
to what your body will experience or
suffer through and that's been happening
over the last 36 hours as i've been
preparing for this conversation
and i'm just going to keep going
for a very long time i mean up until age
35 or so
i felt like i had no memories before age
six or five and this type of amnesia
actually showed up a lot
for me uh in the sense that whenever i
had a very stressful set of
circumstances a crisis of some type a
severe
injury i would experience this
dissociation
and i would black out my memory for the
next
let's just call it two to five hours
would disappear i would have no
recollection
of what happened and i didn't have
any memories i could recall or did
recall
about this abuse until five or six years
ago
when i had a number of experiences with
a psychedelic combination of plants
called
ayahuasca and for more on that
we can refer people to other podcasts
where i've talked about this but
at the time let's just call it five
years ago
for sake of simplicity the memory came
up in the end psychedelics are well
known not necessarily in the scientific
literature although there are some
recordings of this but more
anecdotally across thousands and tens of
thousands and millions of
users over time hypernesia so the
opposite of amnesia remembering things
that you haven't thought of
in decades right the color and texture
of the
corduroy couch you had when you were an
infant you know that type of thing
about five years ago i would say i had
these
crystal clear memories of sexual abuse
come to me right the
layout of the house the other kids who
are being
cared for so to speak at the house what
the
mother looked like what the sun looked
like being led up the stairs to the
upstairs bedroom
the floor plan of the house i know
exactly where the house is
i know the driveway i know the names
these are all things that i know and it
came flooding back to me
and at the time i thought to myself huh
that's interesting that definitely
happened i remember that happening
and it came back to me in high
resolution
but i didn't feel any suffering
associated with it and i
talked it away i put it back in the box
locked the box
and that was that until
i had my first 10 day vipassana silent
retreat
and thankfully had jack cornfield there
as one of the the lead facilitators
and to increase the depth of the
experience i'd fasted beforehand so i
was fasting for about five days
and then began to use
increasing dosages of silica mushrooms
which contain psilocybin so i started at
300 milligrams went up to 600
and ultimately landed at 900
and i want to say around day six
of this silent retreat all of this
abuse came back to me like a
tidal wave and it was
replaying as if i were wearing a virtual
reality
headset i was immersed i wasn't an
observer i was actually being
traumatized and re-traumatized 24 7
for this period of time any moment that
i was awake this movie was playing
and i would sweat through my sheets at
night
fall asleep for an hour to then wake up
to go back into meditation and the movie
would start again
and i was so
distraught there's so much anguish and i
felt like
i was either already having a psychotic
break
or certain to have a psychotic break and
that i would not be able to manage life
when i left the silent retreat that i
sought out
jack as an emergency to spend time with
him and speak with him
and uh he really saved me like he was
the safety net
so i i owe a huge debt of gratitude to
jack
who's not just an incredibly adept
mindfulness
practitioner but also a clinical
psychologist and he's worked with
many many many different types of trauma
vets
victims of sexual abuse you name it very
broad spectrum so i really owe him
huge thanks and it was at that point
after that
that jack made a number of
recommendations for
resources that we'll talk about later
but included books by peter levine like
waking the tiger
the body keeps the score by bessel van
der kolk and
a handful of other things it was at the
tail end of that retreat that i realized
you know these
let's just call it 17 seemingly
inexplicable
behaviors of mine these vicious cycles
or
triggers that i had been treating like
separate things
separate problems to be solved we're all
downstream of this trauma
if that makes any sense i don't know if
you've had this experience but i was
like oh
now that you click that puzzle piece
into place
these really strange behaviors this
self-loathing
this rage that was seemingly
so exaggerated and disproportionate
leading to say the near suicide in
college which was
as close as you can get to taking your
life without actually doing it
all these things fell into places making
sense
and you know on one hand there was this
relief that it made sense
and that i wasn't broken in all these
different ways
i just sort of suffered this acute
trauma
and blocked it and it was also very
overwhelming because i didn't
necessarily know how to work
on this root cause right this trauma
and that's when the direct
work began i just i cleared everything
in my calendar
and everything waited like
everything they could wait waited and
you know these memories at that point
started to
trickle up to awareness i'll just give
another example that i've never spoken
about publicly
which is in elementary school you know
feeling numb
and priding myself on pain tolerance
right this ability to dissociate
and for whatever reason really well for
obvious reasons i guess wanting to
develop
the ability to withstand pain and
you know for a very short period would
bring this pocket knife to school
and press it into the back of my left
thumb i remember this really clearly
until my thumb would start to bleed and
then i'd move it a millimeter or two and
then press it into my thumb and make it
bleed
and do this over and over again without
changing my facial expression i'm in
class i'm sitting in math class
doing this right looking at the
blackboard tracking things and
fortunately for me after a short
time of doing this scared myself
by doing it and stopped but it didn't
strike me as particularly strange
at the time yeah you were you were
relieving pain
you were you were using that as a way to
be able to release some of
your trauma without even knowing it i
i certainly think that could well be the
case
and you know part of the reason that
i've held off on this conversation also
is that
for a long time after the realization
after ayahuasca felt like this did not
affect me that it was a bad thing that
happened
but who am i to complain i discounted it
because of all the other blessings and
privileges that i have in my life
and assume that i could put it under
lock and key
and after the silent retreat and this
let's just call it a psychotic break
which is really what i think it was i
mean whether it's a breakdown or a
breakthrough or both and we could debate
but
i realized that whether you're dealing
with it
directly and putting it in front of you
as
the task that hinders all other tasks
and prioritizing it
or you are not dealing with it
but it's creeping out through the
corners and affecting you
in ways that you may not even be aware
of like you're dealing with it
whether or not you choose to deal with
it exactly
and so i began working this is a few
years ago
on compiling this this book on healing
and
i'm very fortunate in the sense that
this sexual trauma never seemed to
affect
my sex life right my sort of vitality in
sex
i was it was one of the few places
actually that i felt integrated
and felt period right where i actually
felt deeply without dissociating
and so i started working on this book
the healing book and i was
writing this chapter drafting this
chapter
on the abuse and part of the reason it's
taken us
so long to have this phone call is
because i've been afraid of it
i i wrote this chapter this draft and it
totally [ __ ] me up
i didn't expect it would because i felt
so invulnerable
but the day after i started drafting it
completely lost my sex drive basically
lost sexual function like any interest
or
ability related to sex just disappeared
and that scared the [ __ ] out of me
fortunately that's not you know that
complete paralysis hasn't continued but
i've been
very concerned about taking this one
oasis of feeling that i've had
consistently and [ __ ] it up by
talking about this stuff
well that's that's something that's more
the case
than i think a lot of people talk about
i think that
having any kind of enjoyment sexually
after long-term abuse is really
rare and it's not surprising that you
would have that
response and i'm really happy to know
that you're able to
that that's improved since that
experience it's been a lifelong process
for me
and one that i'm still on to sort of
re-engage from that
first disassociation which you know for
many people that
disassociation is really what saves a
person's life
because you couldn't actually integrate
that level of trauma at that young age
you'd have had that psychological break
then
and likely never recovered totally and
i was chatting with a friend of mine
before this call and i i haven't spoken
to many people at all about any of this
but
he also suffered quite a lot of trauma
and
he said something to me which i've also
thought quite a bit in the last few
years and that is your childhood
adaptive responses are perfect
right like that dissociation in a way is
a miracle of evolution i mean the fact
that we develop this ability to split
our psyche
right and compartmentalized to survive
is really miraculous
and there just comes a point at least
for me
where these old adaptive coping
mechanisms have outlived their
usefulness
and that's been a huge part of my
journey
and uh telling my parents was also
extremely difficult
i was worried about destroying them in a
way if that makes sense right so my
intention had been with this book
to wait until they passed to wait until
they died
to release this so they wouldn't blame
themselves for everything
and what i realized was that that was
too demanding for me as a burden
and i decided to have the conversation
without any expectation of
any response but simply to
give voice to it in a way that would
hopefully free me
from the weight of that being constantly
on my mind
on my subconscious and i
i could probably speak to a few of the
things that i've found helpful and i'd
love to hear from you as well but you
know perhaps
you could speak to because you've been
sort of immersed in the therapy
and treatment and sort of trauma
mitigation
side of things for much longer than i
have could you speak to how common
this type of sexual abuse is yeah
absolutely well first i just want to say
that i love you tim you know you are
such a a good
good man um such a big heart
and a big brain and just so much
generosity
and um it's just an honor to be talking
to you
really um and i i feel very privileged
to be able to have this conversation
with you and
if it does get released i just am so
i'm feeling just so grateful about the
possibilities that it's going to have
to help so many people that need it
i mean sexual abuse is one of the most
common
traumas in the world one in three women
by the time they're 18 will have been
sexually assaulted in some way
the numbers that we know now are one in
six boys
but given how much shame is associated
with boys actually disclosing
my suspicion and and quite a lot of um
clinical psychologist
suspicions uh is that it's much higher
um i i don't know why there would be any
difference frankly
but that's a lot of people um that's a
lot of people that's a lot of young
people
and we as as a species
have so much shame
associated with this behavior
that has been socialized that somehow it
is the victim's
fault i mean just think about what
rape victims go through when they report
how much they have to defend the
believability of their story or what
they might have done or not done to
contribute
so you can only imagine how much shame
there is
for young people that don't know
what is happening to them or why it's
happening to them
so it's pervasive in our world and
it is one of the most devastating
behaviors that someone can enact on
another
at any age if it happens before the age
of 10 because we're all still
developing our brains it changes the
neural pathways in our brains to such an
extent
that the behaviors that i know we're
going to talk about that you've
struggled with and that i've struggled
with are just a normal
way of responding once that kind of
trauma
occurs in for me my trauma
began my sexual trauma began when i was
nine years old
and continued until i was 12 and
it was something that my stepfather did
to me
this was back in the early early 70s
we didn't have the conversation about
sexual abuse that we do now
and i didn't know that it happened
to anyone i thought i was the only
person in the world it was happening to
and i was told by my stepfather that if
i told anybody he would kill my brother
and my mother
and because he was so much bigger and
stronger than me i mean anybody at that
age would have been bigger and stronger
than me any adult um i believed him and
so
i didn't tell anybody after it happened
after my my mother and he ended up
divorcing and there's a
lot of stories around that we don't need
to get into but my abuse was
a part of it but not something that was
known to the degree that it occurred
and then after that another partner of
my mothers also
abused me but i didn't think that but
because i didn't know that it had
happened to anybody else when i was a
little girl
i didn't know how to understand it the
only way that i ultimately found out
that it was happening to anybody else
was through
the anne landers advice column in
newsday where i was i was living
on long island and would read dear anne
landers every day and
one day somebody wrote in about being
abused and
i cut out the article and put it under
my mattress because suddenly i felt like
i
i knew somebody else that that it was
happening to it wasn't just me i wasn't
a freak
um and when i got older
and you know talking to 15 16 17 years
old at that point i thought well i'm not
going to let this impact me i'm not
going to let him
win my life i'm gonna try to have the
best life that i could have
not realizing at that young age as
you've mentioned you know the body keeps
the score you cannot
outrun your own psyche it is not
possible it is just not possible your
psyche is too strong
to just take those experiences
and sweep them under a rug and never
ever look at them again they come back
and um they came back to me when
in in really sort of significant in a
significant way
when a friend of mine died of aids um in
1990 and he wanted to live
so badly and i was 29 or 30
and feeling like i didn't want to live i
knew that i couldn't kill myself but i
didn't want to be living
and the fact that he wanted so badly to
live and died
really for the first time sent me into
you know significant
therapy like everyday therapy for three
years
and then i've been with that same
therapist now
since then so we're going on 30 years of
therapy with the same
doctor now i go twice a week instead of
five times a week but it's been
consistent for that
entire three decades and she saved my
life
she saved my life and that work we did
saved my life but
back to my experience with you i
still up until 2017 or 2018 when i was
first on your show
i was very very
secretive about my past i still felt an
enormous amount of shame
i still felt that it made me damaged
goods
i was not really willing to discuss it
with anyone at any length beyond my
closest closest friends and partners
and i hadn't even talked about it at
length with my family who didn't really
seem to want
to know i had already started working
with the joyful heart foundation with mr
hargitay who's the star of law and otter
svu
and in the q a on my bio
on the joyful heart website i made a
fairly innocuous statement which was
that i felt that being part
of the organization made my life make
sense
because i was helping to eradicate
sexual violence because i was working to
communicate that the rape kit backlog
was something that needed to be
eradicated
you found that bio the rape kit backlog
is
um whenever anybody is raped now in this
country
when they report it they go to the
hospital and they
undertake what is often a multi-hour
often
up to 10 or 12 or 14 hours rape kit
which is
uh where all the dna evidence is
collected so
under your fingernails hair clippings
your entire body is essentially
is evidence and so you undergo
just a forensic um cleaning
where everything is taken all the fluids
all the
ev every bit of dna is collected put
into a kit tested to be able to see if
any dna
is already on record for other other
rape victims
and for many many decades there's been a
backlog
where those rape kits aren't processed
and some of them were in storage and
there's been hundreds of thousands of
rape kits that have been destroyed
because
they weren't in the correct storage or
they were in buildings that were
unclean or unsupervised and
so the joyful heart foundation is
working now right now their main
function is to work to eradicate the rib
kit backlog in this country
um mersh kargitay made an emmy-winning
documentary about it called
i am evidence which is about the backlog
and eradicating that backlog but you tim
when you were
when in preparation for our interview
you found that
that little bio of mine on joyful hearts
website and asked me why working with
the joyful heart foundation made my life
make sense
and in that moment i had to decide
do i disclose to tim's millions and
millions
of people that are listening audience
or do i lie
and i just took one step into
the future and told the truth
and that changed my life because once
you tell the truth a couple of things
happen first of all you realize that
you're not ostracized by the people that
really love you
you are not shamed by speaking your
truth
and people do believe you now that's not
the case with everyone but it was the
case for me
and i felt as a result of that
experience in my life
was fundamentally irrevocably changed
where
i am now someone that
has this experience as part of who i am
but it's not
hidden and it's not ugly
and it's not
loathed it's just part of who i am now
part of my story i'm still going through
a lot of things and we can talk about
that too
and the reintegration and everything
that goes along with it but
but the idea of hating myself because
of this happening because of what it
meant about who i was intrinsically
has fundamentally changed just by the
sheer virtue
of speaking about it in a public way
that isn't hidden anymore so thank you
for that
you're so welcome debbie and i feel so
grateful
for you having done that because the
ripple effect in some ways of that
for me personally is having this
conversation with you yeah and i have to
say that not a week goes by where i
don't hear from
somebody that's listened to that episode
and said thank you
that that episode changed my life and
i just want to thank you and i'm just
overwhelmed by
being able to do that for anybody but it
is a journey and
you know for me it's been a 30-year
journey really more because i did have a
good therapist
prior to seeing the doctor that i see
now that i've been seeing for the
last 30 years but it just wasn't enough
i needed more clinical help than she was
able to provide
and the doctor that i've been with since
has that experience
but you know it's and it's been talk
therapy it hasn't
been aided by um
various other remedies that i've
actually been thinking quite a lot about
but because it's talk therapy talk
therapy is an investment it's
really slow and maybe it's slow for a
reason because you can't necessarily
integrate as much
um i still have you know three days ago
while talking with
my wife and my cousin had a major
realization just like in the midst of a
conversation like holy [ __ ]
um and and so you know those things
happen
just because of doing that work for so
long but there's no
way to predict when those breakthroughs
are going to happen
yeah i'd love to also take a moment just
to say
for people listening who either know
they have suffered abuse
or trauma right it doesn't have to be
sexual abuse but some type of trauma
capital t
or little t number one it's highly
individualized you can have
two veterans who are in the same foxhole
in
wartime who respond completely
differently so there's no sort of
objective scale of
or descriptor of events that qualify as
trauma or non-trauma
but i'll speak specifically to people
who have suffered
sexual trauma and i'll say a few things
the first is and i feel this way about
you debbie that
as someone put it to me once you have
made
your trauma part of your medicine
meaning
that you have the ability to empathize
and deeply feel other people
and let's face it i mean that's
somewhere between like one-sixth and
one-quarter of the world's population if
not more
yeah you have the ability to empathize
and resonate
and potentially help people in a way
that you would not possess had you not
gone through what you went through
if that makes sense absolutely
absolutely
and so for me reframing it
as to say a gift may be
too strong and i don't want to paint it
unilaterally in that way but to
to be able to turn the perspective so
that you can see
how you can wield it for good as opposed
to be
contorted by it as a passive experience
it is possible to use this i think as a
superpower of sorts
to really help other people and for me
helping other people heal has helped me
heal
and working on your own healing in turn
helps you
to help others to heal so it is a
virtuous cycle
it has been at least for me and i really
want to underscore for people listening
that right now in my life i have more
light
and joy and compassion
and feeling of
safety and security and optimism than
i've ever had in my life
and that is for me at least a product
of different being
blessed to find and also having
discovered different tools
that have been exceptionally
exceptionally helpful
and certainly having someone in my case
jack cornfield to act as a safety net
and so i want to
before we discuss some of the things
that have helped because i'd really like
to
to offer people some tactical
recommendations and i will put this in
the show notes
everything will be in the show notes for
the podcast
and i'll also create a short link which
is tim.blog
forward slash trauma with resources
neither debbie
nor i or medical professionals so i have
to say that but we can share what has
worked for us
and been helpful i would say that for me
deep immersive experiences and i can
speak to different modalities
have been critical in
remembering in the conventional sense
what happened and also remembering
right piecing back together these parts
of myself
in a uh ultimately
uh really integrative and beautiful way
i mean certainly more beautiful than
viewing myself as a broken toy some
flawed object that was
you know loathsome and when you have any
of these deep immersive experiences
or perhaps even if you do talk therapy
things can come
up very strongly that you may or may not
be ready for
and for that reason i was just
lucky very lucky that i went into this
10-day silent retreat and certainly
augmented it with all these various
intensifiers
and what i had done in retrospect was i
got on a trapeze without checking the
net first
and i was just [ __ ] lucky that jack
happened to be there pulling out the net
as i was losing my grip so i think it's
extremely important before you go into
any intense potentially intense or
immersive
therapy or experiences that you have
someone who is in your corner as a
safety net who has experience with
handling
ideally the type of trauma that you
suspect
you've gone through possibly went
through and who is comfortable handling
crisis situations
at least that's my perspective because
if i had not had that honestly i don't
know what would have happened
yeah i agree it's it's absolutely
critical to
have people that you trust
in your life that can catch you
if you need to be caught yeah and so i'd
love to just list off a few of the
things that i found particularly
helpful in the toolkit and not to imply
that these will resonate for all people
but
first i'll recommend books and these
were recommended by multiple people
there are a few the drama of the gifted
child which is really the drama of the
sensitive child
and i discussed that with gabor mate in
my podcast with him at one point or
rather he discusses it
waking the tiger which is peter levine
the body keeps the score
and a lot of these relate to what peter
might call somatic experiencing
since at two to four in my case i'm not
cognitively creating spreadsheets and
pro and con lists
and over intellectualizing this it's
it's like a very
psycho emotional and physical experience
of trauma
and in my case at least tools
that approach it from that angle
have been very helpful including
psychedelic
medicine work which i'll touch on in a
moment on the non-psychedelic side
internal family systems something called
ifs and this is this is
one form of what might be referred to as
parts work
the creator so to speak of this is
richard c
schwartz and the use of ifs
in combination with the
the performance-enhancing drugs of
trauma work which i consider
psychedelics
such as psilocybin or we might call an
empathogen
like mdma and i'll come back to that ifs
looks at the mind and i'm simplifying
here but as a set of discrete sub
personalities
so you can in the course of this type of
talk therapy
have a conversation with anger
like the part of you that is deeply
angry you can have a conversation
amongst these different parts the part
of you that is ashamed the part of you
that is resentful the part of you that
is sad and you can
recognize and fully feel these emotions
in a way that was not accessible to me
otherwise
and this type of parts work is actually
very well implemented by an organization
called maps
maps.org in their use of mdma which is
going through phase three trials right
now
for mdma assisted psychotherapy for
post-traumatic stress disorder so for
those of you
who are familiar with my support of
psychedelic science
and have wondered about the missing
piece this podcast
may explain one of those pieces
a few other things non-pharmacological
that could be of help to people hacomi
therapy h-a-k-o-m-i
and i should say two incredible
practitioners of parts work
who have done incredible work with maps
are michael and annie mithoffer i'll
link to these names
in the show notes hakomi therapy
h-a-k-o-m-i
which is something that i found very
helpful
for learning to feel again after a
lifetime of
numbing and dissociation so
as a kid who is in retrospect very very
very sensitive
all of what happened was just such an
utter assault on my senses that it
obliterated my
capacity or desire to feel anything
and it's been a process to relearn how
to feel
and to embrace that sensitivity as a
gift and not just a liability
so comey therapy in terms of
couples work so helping my partner my
girlfriend to
better understand how this has affected
me imago therapy
i am ago has been
very very helpful in effectively
explaining how silence or
feeling a necessity to self-censor
or not speak truth leads me to feel
ashamed and dirty and damaged that i
have a very
strong need to be able to speak truth
and the cost is very high if i don't
so any type of self-censoring that feels
like silencing
if i feel like i need to withhold or
avoid giving feedback
and i don't always have the most
non-violent communication style
so imago therapy has been
very helpful as has studying non-violent
communication
which people can find quite easily just
a few more things
and again i'll put these on the show
notes recently and this is just in the
last few months
two things one is hrv training that's
heart rate variability training which
i've been doing with dr leolagos
who is an incredible practitioner and
this involves
tracking your heart rate and respiration
using feedback devices
and working through
your physiology in my case i'm hyper
reactive
to any type of stressor so i have a
panic response given my history can and
there are other types of trauma that
i've experienced
i was very badly physically bullied up
until sixth grade i mean
school was absolutely terrifying for me
for a long time
that plus sexual trauma plus other
things have led me to be very
cardiac hyper responsive even a minor
disagreement or a loud noise can send my
heart rate to
100 plus beats per minute where it will
stay for hours and that is a very common
response tim i have that as well um
and a lot of people that have
experienced sexual trauma
um also have that
over compensation in some ways
of responding to stress
fear nervousness
um the unknown you know all of that
triggers a much more
robust uh chemical response in our
bodies
that certainly squares with my
experience over decades
and this hiv training has been very
surprisingly effective and what i like
about it is that it's
turning the more common paradigm
of working through words and your
psychology to down regulate your
physiology it's working on physiology
first it's saying let's reverse the
arrow of causality and let's work on
physiology to change your psychology
and that's been a real epiphany for me
and has helped me to realize when i'm
projecting dissociating has been a real
revelation of sorts
so that's a new addition but it's been
very powerful
and in combination with
advice from a podcast guest actually jim
detmer
who's just incredible and part of the
conscious leadership group
who has helped me to utilize
a a lens that i think can be very
pragmatic and i do have part of me
that's skeptical of the enneagram but
there are
many people i respect toby lutky ceo of
shopify or
i could go through a very long list of
names people would recognize who used
the enneagram
for preventing conflict
and just greasing the wheels of
interpersonal communication there's a
book called the complete enneagram by
beatrice
chestnut and i've been very skeptical of
the enneagram because it
reads to me often like a horoscope of
sorts like astrology and
nonetheless i was typed this came after
an interview with someone who's
qualified to do this
as a what's called a self-preservation
six and there are there are other
aspects to this but it so
well captures the hyper vigilance
and fear-based orientation that i've had
my whole life
towards the world and towards myself
quite frankly
that it has been an incredible
complement
to the hrv training and i would say the
performance-enhancing
drugs that have been layered on top of a
number of these
and that are also incredibly potent in
and of themselves
are mdma psilocybin in ayahuasca for
purposes is this discussion because
ayahuasca is a very big
gun and people can be knocked sideways
and destabilized
in a way that can last days weeks months
in some cases years i've seen this so i
do speak with some
confidence about this i'm not going to
discuss that as a tool but
certainly mdma and psilocybin mdma
which can be thought of as an m pathogen
some a compound that elicits
openness compassion decreased fear
response
self-empathy right empathogen a
generator of empathy
has been given breakthrough therapy
designation by the fda
is being used very successfully to treat
people with ptsd that has been
unresponsive to treatments
for 15 to 20 years so anyone who is
interested in that i highly recommend
looking at maps.org and psilocybin which
is thought to be the psychoactive
component at least for our purposes in
philosophy mushrooms can also be
synthesized
which is being studied for treatment
resistant depression
and many other conditions opiate
addiction nicotine addiction
which is being studied at places like
johns hopkins which i support imperial
college london which i support and
nyu also many other places but those are
two tools
that when used responsibly
with proper facilitation have been
literal lifesavers for me also and
i will say they're very very powerful
compounds not to be taken lightly and
that are currently schedule one so that
means they are
generally speaking not available for
legal consumption uh there are countries
in the world where that differs
but i want to make sure that the caveat
is clear these are very powerful
and what someone might consider if they
want to
crack the door open to non-ordinary
reality in a way that
might provide insight into
difficult to retrieve memories or simply
to explore that terrain
there are different types of breath work
like holotropic breath work
that can be helpful without any chemical
agents
to begin to explore this terrain and
even without any type of
compound any type of ingestion of
plant medicine or synthetics these can
bring up
very powerful experiences that require
the safety net i referred to earlier
having a therapist of some type i'm
still a fan of cognitive behavioral
therapy
like i mentioned ifs internal family
systems there are a few that i have
personally found very helpful
i think somatic experiencing is has a
role to
play a la peter levine and i'm going to
stop there because that's
quite the list and anyone who's
interested in how
i might sequence psychedelics
specifically breathwork etcetera i
should listen to my blake mykoski
interview separately but debbie i would
be really curious to hear
what you recommend when people reach out
to you
say in a very raw place where they've
realized perhaps that they have this
trauma that they need to deal with it
but they don't know what to do
what do you say i say a lot of the
things that you're saying
about being able to
engage with a therapist that will help
you through your
journey now everybody has their own
journey to take
some people will want to do things that
are more conventional make them feel
safer some people have a much higher
tolerance
for risk or the uncertainty of an
experiences outcome
and will be very
comfortable engaging in more alternative
paths and i think it's really
important for people to understand
that their path to healing is very much
their own path to healing
in the same way that everybody has their
own path to love
or success or family
so that is something that is really
personal
i think offering these types of
alternatives for people to consider is
a gift so that people can really
investigate
what they're most comfortable
experiencing
and undertaking for me when i first
started my
journey i was desperate for help
and through a friend she recommended a
therapist and for the first six years of
my therapy
and that was in my 20s prior to engaging
with the doctor i have now
i was doing group therapy i was doing
individual therapy i was doing some
family therapy
it wasn't as rigorous as what i
ultimately
went towards but i actually don't think
i would have been ready for a five-day
analysis which is what i first engaged
with
um relational therapy had i
not had that prior six years of
beginning to reveal who i was
and why i was who i was so for me that
six years
of less medical therapy i guess that
would be the way to put it
was really beneficial to me and then in
1991 when i started my therapy the kind
of therapy i'm
now that started as five days a week
then four then
three and now two how long did you do
the five days a week before you went to
four and how long the four days week
before you went to three
just guesstimate yeah absolutely um i
did five days a week
for um three years and i did it on my
lunch break i actually
found a therapist very very
serendipitously that was
within walking distance to my office at
the time
and did that walked to therapy
and then walked back to work and so it
was a 45 minute session so my lunch
break was an hour and a half
and i did that for three years it was
enormously expensive
i was completely broke as a result
it took all of my resources to manage
this
but it saved my life
and so when people talk about the cost
of therapy
i like to think about it more as an
investment in your life
and if this is going to make your life
better it's going to make it more
integrated if it's going to make it
healthier
then why would you want to spend your
money on anything else
but that so i did that for three years
and then i went down to four and i think
i did
four times a week for
um about another year or so
and then did three times a week for
the bulk of my therapy i would say
for probably 20 plus years and in those
early sessions what did those look like
and i'm asking is someone who's done
very little talk therapy because
i've had an aversion to words in a sense
rightly or wrongly
because i know friends who have really
been saved by
talk therapy what did a or might a
session
look like what do you talk about what's
the format yeah i mean i think for me
and that's so interesting
you know the different responses people
and bodies have
to their trauma i have
often joked and maybe it's not really
that funny but i
i positioned it as a joke that that i am
just ahead
and that i'm not my head has it's been a
i don't know that my head is even still
fully connected to my body
i am very cerebral and you know my wife
knows this my former partner maria
popova we joke about it all the time
um that i just love to talk i i am a
talker i like to analyze
everything and being connected to my
body is
much much harder for me and
so i'm very comfortable
face to face with someone looking at
them
looking into their eyes and
engaging intellectually and verbally
being connected to my body is still
still something i struggle with tim and
so initially
the therapy that i think my therapist
was
was hoping i'd get to would be facing
away from her
on a sofa sort of very old-fashioned in
a lot of ways
because then you can really engage
with your subconscious in a in a much
faster way you're not
looking at someone's face to analyze
their response
people like you and i who are highly
empathetic
often will organize
the way that we speak what we say
based on almost imperceptible
facial recognition patterns that we
understand
and to disengage with that allows you to
go deeper
into your own subconscious to not be
assessing what the response is and how
you are engaging with that response
while you're responding
there's a whole set of clinical
responses and engagements that happen
when you're speaking
body language facial patterns that
we assess really quickly that we you
know that gift that you were talking
about before we have that
and and quite a lot of people that have
gone through intense trauma
have this ability to almost
be able to calibrate the energy around
someone
to be able to assess how we can best
respond
to them for their comfort um i was
unable to do that
i needed to be face to face and still to
this day
so now i'm i've been doing my therapy
for over a decade now
probably maybe close to a decade online
and she my therapist sort of retired
from her
big time practice and now has a much
smaller practice
and i'm still working with her and so we
do the therapy
over skype and we've been doing that for
as long as skype exists and um
that's been really helpful as well i
don't need to be
in person but i do need to be face to
face
and so that's still something that is
really important to me that's also i
think
part of why my podcast has been as
successful one because most of my up
until
kovid all of my episodes have been face
to face
i look deeply into a person and feel
them and experience them in a way that i
can't really
replicate any other way so in any case
the first those first therapy sessions
were just a matter of
allowing myself to fully break down
which is
why when brian died i was in therapy at
that point but then
did go much deeper after that because at
that point
i needed to go on some pharmaceutical
antidepressants or my therapist was
going to recommend that
i um can you just remind
me and listeners of who brian is oh
brian is the friend that i mentioned
that died of aids
he desperately wanted to live i was
perfectly healthy in my body
you know clinically but didn't want to
live anymore
but didn't feel like i could ever take
my life but did no longer want you to be
living
so sort of became a bit paralyzed in my
ability to engage with the world so at
that point
my therapist suggested that i either
begin to think about an antidepressant
to help calibrate my
emotions or to be
admitted to a hospital and so
i decided to try i went on an
anti-anxiety medication and then
at that point started on prozac prozac
takes about six weeks to really kick in
um so that was a really rough six weeks
but it did help take a bit of the edge
of the despair away i think a lot of
people
don't fully understand what
anti-depressants do they don't make you
happy
they're not in any way happy pills but
they are
able to give you a sense of the bottom
of your despair in a way that
not being on them did for me i'm just
going to talk about me
and so it allowed me to feel like there
was a bottom to the despair
so i didn't feel like i was falling
through the ether
and was going to just end up crashed on
the ground
i'm so glad we're having this
conversation and
i want to speak to something you just
mentioned which is that
onset period for many ssris
where you have a period of a handful of
weeks
before which the effects can be felt
right
that can be a very dangerous period for
people if they're suffering from
suicidal ideation fantasizing about
suicide perhaps planning suicide
and i will say in such cases and i don't
recommend
this much but ketamine
can be a very effective acute treatment
for stopping loops of suicidal ideation
it can be very effective intramuscularly
or intravenously
there are clinics that provide this in
the u.s it's
generally very well tolerated it's a
very well studied compound because it's
an
it's a dissociative anesthetic that has
been used for
many many years and uh is on the
world health organization list of most
essential medicines so for those
who are in a very acute dark place that
may not allow them to last those weeks
until ssris have their
felt effects i would just mention that
as
a potential intermediate sort of stop
gap lifeboat for people and i did have a
medication that i took
in that six weeks to help me as well and
and that did help now i also
want to let people know that sometimes
antidepressants can stop working
so i started taking prozac in 1991
and then in 2003 inexplicably it stopped
working
and i went back into a place where
i no longer wanted to be alive and for
me it wasn't about
i'm going to kill myself now it was just
a matter of being unable to
exist in any real world
experience i was in my home
in bed unable to move and unable to do
anything
one of my dearest friends who's no
longer alive but she
would come to my house and hope that i
wasn't dead i didn't
want to kill myself i just didn't want
to be alive
and so at that point i then
went back into sort of an emergency
situation
with my psychopharmacologist who then
prescribed zoloft and i started taking
zoloft and i've been on zoloft ever
since
and that works much quicker you start to
feel that within three days
um you actually do feel your brain
being impacted by this drug it's a very
different experience than prozac
and did feel my brain actually felt
like it was moving and then we worked on
the right dosage
and i've been on that dosage ever since
but it is
really important when you're engaging
with any type of pharmaceutical
to not only be working with your
therapist
and your psychologist but also to be
working with a psychopharmacologist
who is a medical doctor who is going to
prescribe
medicine based on your body type your
body chemistry
and then in as much as i'm still taking
the same dosage
i have to have twice yearly
appointments with him to make sure that
i'm still on the right medication and
the right dosage
so it's very important to be monitored
by a medical doctor
when engaging with any pharmaceutical
drugs
and do not stop anything called turkey
absolutely
absolutely important yeah having the
right medication is really important
some people work really well with
wellbutrin i know a lot of people on
wellbutrin
the original potential drug for me was
wellbutrin and
i felt like i was going to die
did not work well for me at all i
actually felt like i might have a
psychotic break
and so i did have to stop taking that so
there is a time where
and some people have to have a different
cocktail of drugs i know
quite a number of people because i'm
open about taking antidepressants i know
i talk about it a lot with people and
there are people that have to take two
or three different types of
antidepressants to get the right
chemistry
mental illness is a brain problem
that has to be investigated
as a way to regain the right brain
chemistry and that is something that is
not always easy to find
yeah i'd like to speak to something you
said earlier which is
i think important at least it has been
important for me to unpack
as someone who almost committed suicide
in
1999 and that is you said you didn't
want to die
but you didn't want to live right and an
observation that was drawn for me by
stannis lovegroff who's a
psychotherapist not sure he would
consider himself
psychotherapist i'm not sure what label
he would apply but very experienced
psychotherapist who's supervised
thousands
of sessions over his 80-plus years of
life
involving psychotherapy and also
assisted psychotherapy with compounds
like lsd and other things
and i'm going to paraphrase this but he
said that a desire to
kill oneself can be thought of as a
desire
to destroy your physical body but it's
not a desire to destroy
your physical body it's a desire to kill
your ego
and to stop the loops that you're
experiencing
right right it's it's it's a desire at
least for me
a desire for some type of relief
from the relentless looping
of these thought patterns that seemingly
would not stop
just like being in the impact zone in
the ocean where you're getting hit by
wave after wave after wave i just wanted
the waves to stop
and the only option that i felt was
available
was to take my own life which thankfully
i did not do
people can hear my ted talk for kind of
how that unfolded but the part that was
left out of the ted talk
is that i had planned to kill myself i
had the exact
plan laid out i knew exactly how and
when i was going to do it and
by sheer luck i had requested a book
dealing with suicide from firestone
library at princeton and i'd forgotten
to change my mailing address i was away
from school i was taking a
time away from school which surprise
surprise was recommended by the
administration because they don't want a
suicide on their watch
if someone seems mentally unstable and i
had forgotten to change the mailing
address to where i was
then living off campus so a postcard
when the book was available
went home to my parents and my mom got
the postcard
and she called me with a very shaky
voice and asked me about it and that
snapped me out of it because
i had only been thinking about really
myself and the impact that it would have
on me i was so stuck in my own loops
that i had not thought about the impact
it would have on other people and as
someone
later put to me you know killing
yourself is like taking your pain
times 10 and inflicting it on the people
who love you the most
so that snapped me out of it but that
was so lucky so
lucky if if you think about how that
would have turned out differently now it
would have been an email or some type of
notification that i would have archived
and
i would not be here so i came very very
close and at the time it's because i
viewed the only option
for extinguishing the loop was to kill
myself and
what i've learned since is that it is
possible
and i'm not a hammer looking for the
nail in the sense that i'm not
recommending
these tools for everyone they do not
address everything they have risks they
have side effects but
tools like ketamine tools like
psilocybin
in some cases with trauma mdma for ptsd
with qualified facilitators and
therapists
allow you to do what i so desperately
wanted
without killing yourself right and
so i want to just emphasize to people if
you feel
that you're fatally flawed in a way that
dooms you to unhappiness and
self-loathing and a desire to kill
yourself
don't believe everything that you think
because as i learned later even though
that seemed true in the moment that is
not true there are tools
and options available to you you know
debbie one thing i'd love to ask you is
are there any
books or resources or organizations that
you found
particularly helpful or that you've
recommended to people that they've found
helpful
yeah and tim i just want to caveat i
know
that um i was talking to roxanne about a
book that
we've both been really helped by and
it's called a courage to heal by ellen
bass
but i've heard since that there's that
there's some problematic
issues in that and i don't know if it's
because of the way that they talk about
trans i don't know um so
that book was enormously helpful to me
as was um
bessel vander kulk's books they still
continue to be helpful
and i'm happy to to say that sort of
separately again so that it's good for
the podcast but
i i don't know let me look into what
issues there might be
because i don't want to give anybody
information that or or recommend a book
that that's problematic for any reason
yeah and i'll also say we can put the we
can put any
disclaimer in the show notes for people
the courage to heal
workbook has also been sent to me and
was recommended by someone with
a lot of in the trenches experience
working with
trauma survivors i will confess
that i did not actually have the stomach
to go into it because i was coming off
six months of very deep intense work and
just could not
even digest the possibility of going
through
a 200 or 300 page workbook yeah so i
have not cracked it but it was
recommended by someone who i
respect tremendously as a clinician so
we can put that
in the wall yeah definitely i mean the
drama of the gifted child is a book that
i also read when i so so
i as as i mentioned earlier the first
sort of 25 up till about i was about 23
24 i was in this mode of this didn't
impact me
i'm not gonna let this uh destroy my
life
i'm not gonna let him win this is
something i'm gonna overcome and have
the best possible life for
and i think a lot of people feel that
way and then it comes everything comes
crashing down
and i ended up at a party
it was about a year or two after i
graduated college
and somebody that i admired a great deal
heard about a job that i had gotten
and said to me oh debbie i'm so jealous
of you and
i just stood there and looked at him and
thought how could he possibly be jealous
of me i'm the
the most disgusting ugliest
uh unworthy person on the planet and
that's when i decided i needed to go
into therapy for the first time
and when i did the gates opened they
really did
i remember being at um
at the at the brooklyn academy of music
watching
einstein on the beach and something
triggered me
in that performance and i went home and
spent two days in bed
just weeping um at
who i was and what i was in my life and
at that point
really tried every possible at that
point this is the 80s now we're talking
about
every possible book workshop
nutritionists
um any any way that i could find
to try to be better to try to feel
better to try to
change who i was and um
a lot of it was sort of trying at that
time for quick fixes you know i
didn't want to have to i
the idea at that point if anybody told
me at that point
that i would be 58 years old as i am now
still working on these things i i
might have packed it in you know i was
like why do i have to deal with
something that
occurred in the first 18 years of my
life for the rest of my life but that's
those are the cards that i was dealt and
my brain
developed in the way that it did with
the neural pathways that it did
with the panic response that it has and
what i can say
is that with all the resources that i've
undertaken
they're all worth it in some way shape
or form because they are
all moving you forward to a path that
isn't completely um
catastrophized by what happened to you
in in your early
in the earlier part of your life and
gives you a way
to re-create different
neural pathways that lead you to
the way that you want to live your life
and the way that you want to think about
your life in a way that's healthier
um so so some of the books that i read
in my 20s and 30s
ellen bass is the courage to heal and
her accompanying book
workbook um the drama of the gifted
child
which as you said is the gifted child is
really the more sensitive child or
a sensitive child um vessel vander
kulk's books
website resources anything that he's
written
um has helped me um because of
where we do keep the score which is in
the body and
in addition to my journey as
a businesswoman as an entrepreneur as a
brand consultant and strategist as a
podcaster as an artist a writer an
illustrator whatever it is
there's always this parallel path
of being a person that's looking to
understand my motivations my place in
the world my purpose
my trauma and how i can integrate all of
that together
so that anything i do in my life
isn't just a response to the trauma
isn't just i'm doing this to feel
productive in the world
because i felt so meaningless i'm doing
this to feel
meaning because i don't have any sense
of who i am
and that's something that i think i
might be doing for the rest of my life
at this point
but for me it's trying to find
and contentment
about who i am and doing what i
do because i love doing it and not
because
i feel that if i don't do it i'm nothing
that's really important it's extremely
important
and it's
it resonates with a
i suppose it was a realization that i
that i had prompted by
something that tara brock either said or
wrote
tar brock very well known mindfulness
teacher
absolutely yeah i've taken her she's
incredible yeah
incredible incredible teacher her book
radical
acceptance uh which has a very generic
title but
very impactful content for me at least
radical acceptance and i'm going to come
back to that word acceptance because i
think it's critically important
she said or wrote at one point and she
was quoting
some apocryphal stage but that there's
there's only one question that really
matters
and that is what are you unwilling to
feel
yes and i've thought about this a lot
because the stories we tell ourselves
the life experiences including trauma
that we've had
drive our behavior and drive our reality
right this the stories that we tell
and what i realized about myself is that
increasing my pain tolerance focusing on
honing myself as a a weapon of
competition basically
was in large part a way
to busy myself and over stimulate myself
including with caffeine and stimulants
and so on
so that i wouldn't feel certain things
and this was subconscious it was
it was not something that was in my
conscious awareness it was subconscious
but in retrospect
that is what i was doing i did
not want to be in a room by myself
with things bubbling to the surface
right if i was at a slow simmer i wanted
to take something else that was
boiling at a loud boil and pour it on
top of that to
create enough noise that i wouldn't feel
whatever
needed to be felt that is so common
absolutely
i did the exact same thing yeah super
common and the
part of the reason that internal family
systems ifs as i mentioned or something
like it
in parts work has been so helpful to me
and you know jack cornfield is also very
very good at this type of parts work and
i'll speak to something that
that i've done that has been very
helpful in a minute
is recognizing and not
hating or hurtfully judging
your coping mechanisms so i i have
historically had
no tolerance for weakness very little
tolerance for weakness so any type of
fear
any type of shame was weakness and just
was meant to be eradicated right and for
me
i just had no tolerance for weakness and
as a result i i hated parts of myself
which ultimately just does not
it work really really does not work uh
and and if you want to be a better
competitor
by the way this does not remove your
edge it actually gives you greater
awareness and i think an ability to
to not uh leak energy
all over the place that you could
otherwise point
at a worthwhile target so the parts
practice in ifs
has been a revelation and i don't use
that word lightly i've used it a few
times but i'm using it with very
specific things that have actually
warranted that type of word
because the coping mechanisms right if
you want to curl up in a fetal position
and just let things
happen let things pass if you have anger
that you've suppressed and you judge
that anger because it's caused damage
in certain areas of your life these are
very often
what might be called protectors these
are things that allowed you to survive
and they're like vestigial tales they're
coping mechanisms that
served a critical purpose at some point
that perhaps are just now the only gear
that you go to or one of three default
responses reactions i should say that
you have and
if you disown them if you hate them they
you will deal with the ramifications and
it's messy but if you're able to
honor them and thank them for their
service
and gently put them on the table put
them on a shelf
because you don't need them right this
minute when you're having a huge
over reaction physiologically and
emotionally to some small
ripple in your life it's much easier to
find peace
and jack cornfield has been
very helpful for me in this respect and
we've talked about this in a number of
episodes uh on the podcast
for people who are interested and one
thing that he
suggested that i do and i'm simplifying
this greatly but it doesn't need to be
complicated
is to a few times a day or during
say love and kindness meditation to go
back
to the the terrified unprotected
younger version of myself and to
give that younger tim what he needed at
the time what he craved
and to tell him everything's gonna be
okay and to console that
younger version of myself to protect
that younger version of myself
and the easiest way i found to implement
that was by
doing that type of short meditation at
meals because
setting aside separate meditation time
may or may not happen but you are going
to generally eat
at least once a day and
i would take just a few minutes to cl
not a few minutes excuse me like
20 seconds to close my eyes and do that
before eating
and it had such a tremendous impact and
continues to have such a tremendous
impact on me
it's hard to overstate and it's it's
such a simple concept
but there has been a transfer there's
it's almost like i was able to rewind
the clock
and nurture myself provide myself with
what i needed
so that the long-term consequences are
dialed down
it's it's it's it's been much more
impactful than i could have imagined
given how simple it is
in a way but done routinely that has
been a real game changer for me
it's really quite extraordinary how
plastic the brain
actually is and how you are
able to over time create
different neural pathways that allow you
to respond
differently than you may have in the
past and
quite a lot of people that have
experienced severe trauma
do have that exaggerated panic response
where something
that might not ruffle someone else
that hasn't experienced severe trauma
might see as a minor thing that people
that have
experienced severe trauma will see as
catastrophic that if one small
bad thing happens that means that
everything is [ __ ] that means that
everything is screwed up that means that
you're just
terrible and it's more evidence that
you're not worthy of
being alive or or being happy
one of the things that i think that
dealing with and managing and
re-experiencing
your trauma allows you to do is
metabolize your experiences
in a way that allows you to calibrate
future unhappiness
dissatisfaction frustration in a way
that's
more in measure with the severity of
that thing
at that time as opposed to just de facto
attaching it to all the previous trauma
that then explodes in a much bigger way
yeah yeah they're much less
catastrophizing
yeah i mean i mean that's been my
tendencies here yeah and i and but that
is absolutely
the way that people that have
experienced severe trauma respond
it's if you aren't dealing with and
experiencing and managing that trauma
you never get a place to
to detangle any future trauma
to that past trauma and so they become
instantly attached and that's why that
sort of
giant feeling of everything being that
globalizes that that new trauma or that
new frustration or that new paper cut
whatever it is
to that past trauma happens and
what we don't and i don't know why in in
our sort of dna
this isn't better integrated in our
daily
lives and our experiences of ourselves
but humans metabolize our
our emotions fairly quickly in the grand
scheme of things you know
we we have the ability when we're
hot to take off our sweater
if we're cold we put it back on when
we're hungry we eat
um when we we then we metabolize and
digest our food and
so forth but when it comes to these
types of traumas
there's a fear that somehow re-engaging
with them will destroy us
yeah and it and it won't if
if we have the right tools to help us
through these things
they won't yeah yeah so speaking from
personal experience
you the listener are much stronger
than you give yourself credit for and it
is possible
to debug or rewrite your software
yeah it is possible i'm i'm living proof
of that we both love
and we've both taken very different
paths to it you know i
mine is far more conventional um but
but they but they've worked you know
they've worked i could
never have imagined that i could have
this type of life and
i'm also not finished with the work and
they're still i'm still on this
this path and this journey to recovery
and i probably will be for the rest of
my life and there are moments where i'm
like
gee what would i have been like if i
didn't have that trauma
and there are moments where i feel sorry
for myself and there are moments where
i wish it you know it could have been
different but it can't and it's not and
i move on and
i just have to figure out a way as we
all do
to work with what i got and
you know part of what people have asked
me
over the years you know why are you so
resilient why are you still in therapy
why are you still doing
why do you still try so hard and
ultimately and i think that perhaps this
is why you and i
both didn't kill ourselves is that at
the end of the day
i feel like i have one notch more hope
than i do shame and i think that about
you too tim you know why
are you working so hard to create a
better life for yourself
to understand your motivations to
integrate your
your trauma and i believe the same to be
true for you
you have more hope about what your life
can be
about than you do what kind of shame
you have about the life that you had and
and what happened to you
yeah i've never had more hope and
i think uh a part of that is
reframing the work as and this might
sound strange but not as recovery
even though that's a perfectly fine word
to use but just for me
and maybe i'm just too much of a
semantic
like niggler but
it implies to me some type of
incompleteness
like you haven't yet reached wholeness
because you are still recovering and
rather than view it that way from me i
viewed it as
work that connects me to humanity
and the shared suffering that is life
and that i am
training myself to be
a sommelier of suffering
not to increase
the intensity of suffering but so that i
can
not view myself as this independent
island of flaws but rather this
interconnected human
who has the capacity to sympathize and
empathize
because no one has a monopoly on
suffering right and
as someone said to me at some point
everyone is fighting a battle that you
know nothing about
and by going into the
going into suffering
with a somewhat neutral
awareness or a curiosity
it cannot but make you
closer to your fellow humans
i think if you learn to navigate it and
we're all going to face the death of
loved ones we're all going to face
different types of trauma we're all
going to face
betrayal we're all going to face these
common ingredients of the human
experience
and for me
i suppose the podcast and the writing
has been a lifeline as well because i
can take
my experience and hopefully transmute it
into something
that is of service to other people and i
can find some
redemption in that i can i can find some
meaning in it as opposed to
these memories and the
the traumas that are stored somatically
being this this
meaningless infliction of anguish and
horror
and disgust i can
somehow translate that into something
that
is is positive for someone
and you know that's why i've been
thinking about this
some form of this conversation for years
and uh
i'm really optimistic i i have to say
it's taken me a long time to get here
but
there are tools right there are tools
people have also traveled this path
before
i mean for millennia this is not new
and i'll put a whole bunch of other
things in the the resources for people
but my friend neil strauss who's
suffered quite a bit of trauma
has a quick start guide to healing
trauma which is actually a very good
blog post
listing some of the things that have
been effective for him that's a five
minute read
and includes things like the hoffman
process which has come up on the podcast
before
documentaries like trip of compassion i
mean show the before and after
transformations that are possible with
complex ptsd
and i i really feel like
the journey the ongoing work
can be if you frame it
if you frame it in in a way that that
makes possible
incredibly redeeming and gratifying
um and that's not how it started for me
right it started with a why the like i
don't want to deal with this i don't
have to deal with this it's over and
done with
who the [ __ ] am i and i complain there
are people
who are getting raped every day right
now i don't want to deal with this
look at my life i'm fine for [ __ ] sake
let's lock this away and not
look at it again and that just did not
work it didn't work
it doesn't it can't it just it was a
boomerang
and it came back you know 10 times the
size of when i threw it and
there may be people who can do that i
couldn't and tim i i have yet to meet
one
i really have yet to meet anyone that
has been able to integrate trauma in
their lives without
working on integrating the trauma into
their lives
and i don't think there's any there's no
shortcut there's no easy way around it
there's just
it's just if it happened to you to your
body to your mind
it's going to impact and affect you one
thing that i find really helpful is
reading
other stories of people that have
experienced
trauma and how they have integrated that
trauma into their lives chanel miller's
book know my name
eve ensler's written a bunch of books
that have been extraordinarily helpful
in the body of the world and the apology
um these these stories they're these
memories radical acceptance
yeah tara brock's story also um really
have given me
courage and hope and a sense of
mutuality
that i think is much much bigger than
shame
and part of what i'm so hopeful for in
the future
is more people disclose as more people
talk about their experiences the shame
gets shifted to where it really belongs
and that's to the perpetrator
and once we can
see trauma that has been inflicted
on us as not our fault you know that's
one of the reasons i have i have
problems you talk about this semantic
noodling i have problems with the word
victim you know it's just
it i i understand where it comes from
and why it's used but
i i don't feel like a victim and i've
never felt like a victim
nor do i feel like a survivor it's a
process of living
i do think there needs to be some new
language around these
experiences that really are better
um that are more accurate as to what
what we
are experiencing yeah
because it makes us as other and that's
we're not other there is no other
i agree and yeah i've
felt very conflicted about revealing or
not revealing the name of the
perpetrator because i know exactly who
this person is
and at least for now i've decided not to
do it i thought
have you thought about confronting them
i have and i don't think
at least at this point that i i don't
think i'm going to do it um
i and if if he happens to be listening
don't worry at least a few people
know who you are so if anything happens
to me
uh there there is a uh there are a few
things locked in the vault
but the the reason that i decided not to
is because i don't want rage or
vindication or
vigilante justice to be what drives me
and
that rage has been my default for
decades right i mean i've i've always
wanted to return
vengeance upon anyone who harms me or
attacks me tenfold
right i mean smashing flies with the
sledgehammer
and i no longer want
that to be a driver for me
so i've
i've really tried to look at it and
i know this will make some people cringe
but
i mean i don't know how old this sun was
when it happened maybe
i don't know 10 12 14 i really don't
know exactly
but it makes me wonder what happened to
this kid also
right there is i mean this is before the
internet
it's just like how how would that
behavior even manifest
right and it's i'm not trying to wade
into moral relativism where i say it's
okay
it's absolutely not okay it's completely
[ __ ]
and atrocious and damaging
but i've i've tried
to
look at it through multiple perspectives
i actually have confronted my one of my
perpetrators
right um and it didn't quite have
the result that i was hoping and
expecting
could you speak to what you expected and
what happened sure and i also i wrote a
short story about it
called the man which i'll i'll send you
a link to as well
um well um
i had
a person in my life at the time that i
was seeing this is before i came out
i didn't come out until i was 50. um so
at the
before 50 i was primarily dating
men and had been married but i was i was
seeing someone
i had re engaged with somebody that i
had been um who was a high school
boyfriend
and this was when this was um
20 years ago 20 years ago this happened
and
i he knew about my history
and because at the time
my stepfather was still living on long
island where near where i grew up
i was able easily to find him and so
um my my then boyfriend and i
um went to his house my boyfriend was
was rather um was was
bodybuilder so he was somebody that i
felt
could protect me helpful and yeah
helpful enforcer yeah
i mean it's sort of a a complicated cast
of characters which i'll i'll talk a
little bit about
more once i finish this part but um
i decided that with his sort of physical
presence i
i might feel safe going to his to his
house to the stepfather's house and
ringing the bell and saying what i
needed to say
um so i did and i remember it very
vividly you know it's
as you mentioned it's just really
extraordinary what we remember and
what we forget but i i rang his bell i
was wearing a yellow coat
and a black beret and it was the fall
and the air was very crisp
and i rang the bell and his third wife
answered the phone
i mean uh came to the door answered the
bell and
i asked if he was there and
she looked at me skeptically you know
who are you asking for my husband
and i said well i was um that my mother
had been married to him
years and years and years ago and i was
his stepdaughter
she then thought i was
like a prodigal daughter coming back
for reconnection and and family
she didn't know why i was there she she
only saw this as a positive thing
so she squealed she was like oh my god
that's amazing come in and i said no no
actually it's okay i'd like to
just stay here out on the stoop and it
was your husband home
and she's like yes and she like yells
for him and
she's so excited she he comes walking
over
and he looks at me and i looked at the
wife and i said can i can i have a few
minutes with your husband
by myself she's like absolutely of
course you sure you don't want to come
in
i'm like no no i'm good and she scampers
away and
she then yells in the background you
know let me know if you'd like some
coffee
you know it's like surreal
so not what i expected tim so then he
looks at me
and i said do you know who i am and i i
think he maybe was a little bit senile i
don't know at that point he was probably
70
no 60 65 or so
and he said your daughter
i said that's right do you remember what
you did to me
and he didn't say anything he just kept
staring at me in the exact same eyes
he was much heavier and he had a beard
but he was he had the same exact hands
and i was so scared tim i was scared
sounds so [ __ ] intense i was so
scared my heart was beating
i could hear it in my ears
and i said do you remember what you did
to me
and he just said your daughter that's
all he said
again and all i could say and it wasn't
strong enough and it wasn't what i
wanted exactly to say but i was so
nervous and everything had stopped like
time
stopped and the only thing that was
moving forward was my heartbeat and i
just said
you're gonna burn in hell for what you
did to me
and then i walked away
and i left and
there's this really dumb movie called
the specialist with sharon stone and
sylvester stallone
and she has quite a lot of vengeance in
the movie to make up for
her parents being killed by this drug
dealer at the end of the movie sylvester
stallone says
after they've been vigilantes and killed
everybody he says how do you feel
she says better you know
and i relate to that so much like how
did you feel like
better but you know not not not that
much better
that it changed anything about how i
felt about myself
and that again that work still had to be
done by me and only me
[Laughter]
but i still keep tabs on him i know
exactly where he lives i've looked on
google maps
um i keep track of him but i haven't
ever felt the need to do anything more
that's a very intense story debbie
i would be worried that i would kill him
yeah i fantasize
i'm physically i'm physically capable of
it
i if i were to be
in that proximity i would worry that i
would actually
do something that would put me in jail
um yeah we don't want that
no no that would that would not be good
you know i have these because i do work
with marijuana and
have these sort of fantasies about you
know sort of an svu
episode of vengeance um but i i
i i just don't think i have it in me you
know that
that rage you know i still do overreact
to things i still when something bad
will happen i'll feel doomed
but not anywhere is near what it was
what it used to be
and i have become so much more sensitive
to
life and to things that are living that
i don't think i have it in me anymore to
do that
but i haven't forgiven him i i i'm
wondering in
the work that you've done have you been
able to forgive
your perpetrator
i i'm laughing because this
this is a word i've always had great
trouble with me too
me too forgive forgiving forgiveness
only in the last six months is in in any
conventional sense i would say no
i do not find it permissible i'm not
going to have a drink with them
let bygones be bygones
in any conventional sense
i would much rather put a bullet in his
head
but uh the
[Applause]
what i have come to use as a definition
of forgiveness
very recently this is only in the last
year that makes sense to me
because forgiveness almost as a concept
given some of the horrible things that
have happened
just never even made sense it just it
was a nonsensical concept to me
is letting go of hatred forgiveness is
letting go of hatred and if i think of
hatred as you know
swallowing poison and expecting it to
kill your enemy
i have found holding resentment and
hatred to be so corrosive
and so destructive to me personally
right i hold it in like this
hermetically sealed bottle of acid
that just for purely practical
reasons i have come to
view and pursue forgiveness as the
letting go of hatred because i do not
find it serves me
and there's a place for anger
there is a place for anger and i think a
lot of my work that remains to be done
is working with anger and as jim detmer
has put it to me
finding a clean burning anger like an
anger that can be felt fully burned
through
cleanly yes that's key so there is
absolutely so there is no
so there is no residue because i've i've
kept it bottled inside me for so long
for decades but letting go of hatred
as my definition of forgiveness which
i certainly found through someone else's
quote i'm sure
has been helpful so finding a meaning
for that word
has been helpful and that's that's the
meaning
that has been
um most palatable
to me that's that's a definition of
forgiveness that i can get on board with
as you think about forgiveness or
changing the way you view
your rage how does that
help you or how has that changed your
understanding of yourself and your
behavior
oh it's it's it's uh so far and
the the work is not done and
you know in a way i look forward to the
work because
you know as i as i do more work and
learn more then i can
hopefully share more but i will say just
just in the
progress that i've made in the last
handful of years
i've realized through say the hrv
training
looking at my cardiac hyper
reactivity to very small things little
noises
certainly different situations tense
conversations
i have a full-blown
panic response even though i can keep a
calm face
and part of that is retreating
into stories and
so something i repeat to myself and this
is while i'm sober although it began as
a realization
in the space of working with
psychedelics is don't retreat into story
don't retreat into story and retreating
into story means
defaulting to these old stories that
i've used for so long
that i never for decades questioned them
right yeah and one of the stories
is related to personalizing things
so somebody does something
that i take to be a
uh a breach of trust a betrayal of some
type
and it i i begin to spin this story
and construct this narrative of how
this person has completely betrayed me i
am unsafe
these this person is dangerous they are
a threat
i have to cut them out of my life it is
very binary black and white
and i think there's a place for that
there is a place for that i mean the
you know fool me once shame on you fool
me twice shame on me type of mentality i
do think there is a place for that but
it
it it has it has been such a default
like if you choose that as a response
right that is fine if it is a reaction
if you're if you're like a slug that's
getting poked with a stick and you're
just reacting reacting reacting then i
think it's worthy of
yeah if you feel like it's involuntary
sometimes these responses
you almost feel like you don't have any
control over how you respond yeah
right it's just a pavlovian response and
so for me i've i've i've used
observing anger and rage
as a way to try to identify and this
comes back to some of the descriptions
in the enneagram book by beatrice
chestnut which again i'm going to warn
everyone in advance if you're
hyperanalytical like i am and skeptical
it's
a lot of it is going to sound like
astrology so just be forewarned
but the description of the
self-preservation six
including a tendency to project outward
that which
we do not want to feel ourselves
i have realized is a default of mine
right if there's something i strongly
don't want to feel and i can
take that that unease
that fear and provide a target in the
form of someone who has
made a mistake or done something that i
view as a betrayal
having some conscious awareness of
the fact that that is a tendency has
allowed me to
work with anger more
productively right it's it's just
cultivating an awareness
so there's a gap between stimulus
and response yeah
taking advantage of that gap yeah i
think that when
if if someone has the ability to
evaluate their response to anger
and sees that it might be
excessive relative to the experience
it's a way to understand that that's
what your body
has experienced and that's the degree
that you are trying to protect yourself
you know your
your sense of being betrayed or your
sense of being hurt
really is is what it's it's what you're
feeling
the anger is relative to the hurt and
the grief
yeah and i would also say that
looking at it through the lens just as
an exercise of
of using physiology to change psyc to
change psychology right work
working on and training the heart as a
muscle so that you can
take what we think of as an autonomous
function heartbeat and actually gain
some control over it
shows me at least in certain instances
that i'm not creating a story that then
gives me a physical response
i'm having a non-verbal
panic response to a perceived threat
that is
nowhere in my prefrontal cortex i mean
this this predates language
and be then given that really strong
physiological response i'm crafting a
story to justify it
does that make sense absolutely and it's
such incredible insight tim
such self-awareness and look i'm
i'm certainly not the buddha i'm not
rolling around
like the dalai lama uh with with perfect
self-awareness but it is something that
can be cultivated
over time and in my case
it has become clear not always but a lot
of the time
i'm having this almost reptilian
panic response and then my prefrontal
cortex kicks in and within a
nanosecond manufactures a story that
justifies the
huge physical response and then my mind
will find evidence to support that story
yeah absolutely and you can't control
your reptilian brain as hard as we try
you can't will that adrenaline to kick
in it just doesn't work that way
yeah so it's it's it's been uh
it's it's been it's been fascinating to
work at it from both
ends meaning working on the psychology
right using words using books using
resources
exercises that are clearly
prefrontal cortex
to affect my physiology right to calm
myself to decrease hyper vigilance
which is extremely energetically
expensive i mean i've battled fatigue my
whole life
and i think that's a big part of it is
that i'm always
as my friend josh waitzkin would put it
you know i'm always at a simmering
six of like sympathetic nervous system
activation like fight or flight i'm
always at a six
well you're right you're vigilantly
ready
yeah and it's and it's just much more
effective
it's much more enjoyable to be at you
know either a zero or a one and then
being able to
jump to the jump to ten when action is
required but if you're
constantly at a low boil you're just
exhausted so
to to work to work with words to
decrease
that hyper vigilance and to change my
physical response
and then also to work on the physical
response
directly to work on non-verbal
say somatic release and so on to then
relax the cognitive gum
that keeps familiar stories playing
as default and so i've tried to work in
both directions
what kind of work are you doing in that
way
on the physical on the physical
and let's just call it psycho emotional
where you have different types of
physical release
for me it would really be limited to hrv
training
including breath work that's associated
with that that's prescriptive
and
the use of of psychedelics it would be
those two
it would be those two primary toolkits
right now and i know there are other
tools
there are different types of physical
expression and so on
that can be used and that many people
have found
extremely effective and some of them are
in that quick start guide to healing
trauma by neil strauss which which i'll
link to in the show notes
personally i have found
psychedelics or psychedelic assisted
psychotherapy
plus hrv training to be very helpful
from that
for that bottom-up
component that i'm that i was describing
in addition to
the way that you express anger
have you found that your childhood
trauma
has shown up in your life
and contributed to other behaviors
the the way that you work or the type of
work that you do
or your drive uh
i absolutely think so i and i but what
i've
what i think i've become aware of
as a question is
again it's it's very basic but what are
you unwilling to feel
like and the reason i bring that up in
the context
of let's just say work is
if there's something and again much of
this is subconscious that i don't want
to feel or that i'm finding very
uncomfortable i will plunge into
projects and work yeah used work as a
distraction
[Music]
yeah as a way to just overwhelm
whatever the truth of that experience
might be otherwise and
the truth of an experience
i've mentioned the word revelation a few
times sometimes the truth
and the solution is
put right in your face right it's it's
it's
it's a gigantic billboard put in your
face and the message is obvious but
very often for me the truth and the
solution
and maybe the alternative to your
old stories and patterns is a whisper
from across the room
and you really have to pay attention to
get the message and
if you're not subconsciously or
consciously ready to do that
well going through a thousand email and
having 15 conference
calls and committing to three new
projects will
turn on the the music in the room
to such a high volume that you're never
going to hear the whisper and
i think i've voluntarily drowned out the
signal
yeah as a coping mechanism i have to um
yeah so it's a wonderful coping
mechanism because you feel productive in
the world but all it really is is
avoiding the inevitable
right and i've my partner
my girlfriend has been very very helpful
for pointing that out
when i do that okay not that
i should have to rely on the emotional
police
oh but it's just nice to have a support
system it's it's helpful
to have a support system or an
accountability partner somebody who can
who you are going to check in with on a
regular basis who can
[Music]
who can call a spade a spade and
now that that certainly has been very
helpful and i have a few friends who are
doing similar work
and i will say debbie also i have
i have talked about this history of
sexual abuse
with not many people
maybe a dozen uh male friends
let's say and at least half of them
reciprocated with telling me their own
story of sexual abuse it would the
percentage
blew my mind it was at least half and
i i would say maybe closer to 75 i i was
astonished how
how many of my very close male friends
had stories of sexual abuse i mean that
it really it was
staggering uh and that's also given me
some solace
that i'm not in this alone like you said
you thought you were the only person
who'd ever experienced this
right i mean this is a mainstay i hate
to say it but it's
a mainstay of human experience this is a
very
common common experience and it's
particularly hard for boys
it's like there needs to be you know in
addition to the me too movement maybe
there needs to be a he too movement just
so that men can feel
like they can disclose without feeling
shame
i mean i think one thing that would be
really important to talk about
for your listeners for anybody that is
being
disclosed to so if you're someone
and somebody you care about has come to
you and said
and and shared this information what is
that what do you think is the best way
for people to respond to someone
that is being told
yeah because being believed is so
important
yeah well
i can only speak to my experience um
since i wouldn't claim to have this as
an area of expertise but i will tell you
that
the first thing that jack did jack
cornfield when
i was in a complete tailspin i mean i
was
i was really fracturing at every edge
and felt like i was about to
sort of irretrievably break and
when i told him about the history
and i'm paraphrasing here so jack please
forgive me but
he is such an incredible empath and
is such a conscious and focused listener
he listened and he said tim
that's awful and that
never should have happened to you that
never should have happened to you
that should never happen to anyone
and he consoled me and
that meant so much to me and had
such a visceral emotional impact
um
i feel like that was the primary
parachute it's like you have the primary
parachute then you have the backup
parachute and
i've never been asked that question so
i'm improvising here but
the backup parachute which is still so
important to have
might be the prescriptive advice giving
you should do this
here's advice on how to address this but
if he had skipped directly to that
i would have been in no condition to
begin to digest the recommendations it
would have felt
like i was being deflected
so for me the important
the the critical safety net
was just being with me
and witnessing what i was going through
not rushing and
simply saying i'm so sorry that never
should have happened to you yeah that's
the perfect response
people i think always rush to what can i
do to help or how can i
help you get over this and i think just
listening
being present hearing and holding
someone's truth
is is what we need most from the people
that we care about the most
yeah and also and also what he said to
me was you know when this
retreat ends i'm not gonna leave you
like i will not leave you stranded
like i will help you so he just made the
he made it a commitment to be available
to send me
to resources to introduce me to people
who might might be able to help
given his breadth of experience with all
these things
and so those two things i think be
feeling seen and heard and then
being told i'm not going to leave you
alone right i'm not going to leave you
hanging i will help you
because i've during
through all these experiences that we're
talking about i felt completely
unprotected i felt
100 hopeless
and vulnerable right there was there was
no protection
and i've felt that for
decades yeah and to have someone
say in effect you know i have your back
i'm not going to leave you alone
allowed me to exhale enough to get
through the next several
the next several days of that silent
meditation retreat
and and that helps you create these
neural pathways
in understanding that there is someone
that you can trust and that there is
someone that understands you and that
really does help change how you view
yourself and your place in the world
that's a really important experience
yeah yeah it's and i really
certainly if this is ever released i'll
send it to jack but i've mentioned to
him
of course he knows but i've mentioned it
very indirectly and kind of obliquely
and
uh couched language
on previous podcasts with him how
not indebted that's not the right word
because he would never view it as a debt
but just how
grateful i am and how lucky i am
that that he happened to be there
because uh
if he hadn't been there given the
complexity in a sense the intensity of
the experience
i don't know what would have happened
which comes back to the point
that i made really early on in other
words learn from my mistakes
if you go into some very intense
immersive experience
these things can come up i had no idea
this was going to come up i did not
expect this to come up
and i did not have a therapist or
someone else
cultivated and not have that
relationship
to catch me when i came out of the
silent retreat
so i i would just re-emphasize it's
extremely important to have that support
system
that safety net in place before you go
into these deep immersive
experiences whether that's a silent
retreat the hoffman process
psychedelics or otherwise in
understanding
your trauma in in looking to understand
it
and integrate the various
experiences you've had does it change
how you see yourself
and how you see your life to this point
totally the the work has totally changed
it
and i will say that the work
sometimes takes a long time and you can
also have
moments that completely change you in an
instant and
and and if we look at if we look at
change life-changing moments from a
negative perspective
right could could a horrific car
accident change your life in an instant
yes could the death of a loved one
change your life in an instant
yes there are examples
from the healing side of the equation
there are things
that for some people in some instances
can really have
transformative effects a very short
period of time so i i would
say that there are a few things the the
first is
let's look at the title of this book the
drama of the gifted child
right i i have and this is not how this
title is intended
but i've tried to ask myself
how can i turn this into a gift how can
this be a gift
for myself and even more so for other
people
like how can i make meaning out of this
how can i translate this
rather than looking at it as a
shameful fragmented piece of my psyche
that needs to be relegated to some
locked cellar
a compartment rather than viewing it
that way
which i did for several years although i
thought i had banished it successfully
which of course i had not
i've tried to expose it to the light and
to use it to find more light so i think
there's a reframing
that has taken place for me and
if you look at the last few years of my
life and a
an intense dedicated focus to supporting
psychedelic science and phase three
trials
of mdma assisted psychotherapy there's a
reason
that these are the largest certainly at
the time that i made them the largest
financial commitments i'd ever made to
anything
largest energetic time commitments i had
ever made to anything
and the
the the pursuit of and discovery of
tools that actually work
beyond my wildest imagination and my
doubling down and tripling down and
quadrupling down
on
acting as a sort of boundary walker
between different worlds to try to
facilitate
legal change regulatory change that will
make these compounds
in a regulated fashion available to
hopefully millions of people has given
me a tremendous sense of purpose
and rather than keeping my experiences
completely secret speaking to
friends of mine who have suffered sexual
trauma and trying to be a resource
has given me a feeling of tremendous
purpose yeah
i understand that too it's extraordinary
it's heart opening yes it is it's heart
opening and
for me and i think for many people
who've had their their hearts
closed uh or cauterized
seemingly from trauma
it's healing for me to feel that sense
of purpose
right it is restorative and
nourishing to me to take that on
so it's given me a tremendous
sense of of purpose and
i'm happy to be where i am and
[Applause]
what more can you ask for there's more
that there's there's more to do yeah
yeah exactly and there's there's more to
do and honestly i look forward to it i
look forward to it
it's not going to be easy i know that
there will be challenges along the way
there always are
but you know as as someone who i suspect
you know pretty well
um jen 11 has said on the uh
said to me before you know there
there is no underlying path right like
the obstacles are the path
and i'm paraphrasing but like these
these checkpoints these challenges
i try to view these setbacks in some
cases
right where you take three steps forward
and one step back or maybe one step
forward and three steps back
are part of the human experience that's
just the dance
yeah they're they're not reflective of
any unique flaw
that you have and
for me uh and i think jordan peterson
said this i'm
also just going to butcher this quote
but he said you know the point is to
the point is is not to eliminate
suffering it's to find
a sense of purpose that
is so meaningful that the suffering
becomes irrelevant
something along those lines and
i and jordan i apologize if i'm
misquoting you but
even if i am i like it somebody shared
that with me and and i do think that
having a why has allowed me to endure
more than i could have ever conceived
possible and not just endure
by the skin of my teeth but like endure
quite easily
some real challenges it's not always
easy
but those types of reframes
and um
work on my physiology
as an adjunct has brought me to this
place
so a lot of things are different i have
one question i want to ask
if you do release this and people do
listen
what do you want them to take from this
conversation
or what would you like them to get from
this conversation
that's a damn fine question and
i would say at the very core i could
give a very long answer
but the short version is
i would like people to realize and to
believe
that no matter the trauma
they are not alone they are never alone
and it is never hopeless because
i'm speaking to you debbie as someone
who came within a hair's breadth of
killing himself
yes with utter conviction no reservation
and it wasn't necessary
it was not necessary but i had lost hope
i felt like i was
permanently damaged flawed incapable of
feeling happiness
even when things were going well like
objectively i was like my life is good
and i'm unhappy therefore i'm never
going to be happy so what's the [ __ ]
point
let's end this now
you're never alone you're not uniquely
flawed
and it's never hopeless there are tools
there are tools that really [ __ ] work
and if you had told me that
in 1999 i would not have believed you
but having experienced the things i've
experienced
and having seen similar results
in other people and by other people i
don't mean one or two people i mean
dozens of people firsthand
i know there are tools
that work and
there are curative tools that work
so i would just say you're not alone
and it's never hopeless you're never
alone and it's never hopeless there are
tools
that's what i would want people to take
away from this thank you
thank you debbie i think this is this
may be a good place to
to put a bow on it and i'm so grateful
to you
for being such a
a skilled and empathic and loving
midwife and shepherd for this
conversation we've
you've been such a a wellspring of
strength for me to lean on
you've you've taken many late night
phone calls from me when i felt like i
was broken
you could see something i'm getting
emotional um
yeah where i just felt like i was
breaking you know and
it's uh it's been [ __ ] hard at points
it's been really hard and you've all
you've always been there
and
there is light yeah i mean i i can't
i can't begin to tell you how
having the that moment
to share opened my heart
and opened my world and opened my mind
in a way that i could
never ever have predicted
or planned for even and
i think that you know you talk about
you were talking about suffering and you
know we all suffer
and sometimes i think we do everything
in our power to avoid
suffering when the suffering isn't
as hard as the avoidance
yeah and or the isolation right and
so thank you for for
for being there for me and for
giving me the opportunity to be part of
this
you know extraordinary conversation for
me it's just
and it's so interesting because we've
we've had such different
journeys to this moment and
you know if my helping you understand
the benefits of talk therapy is
helpful that makes me thrilled but also
know that
you're talking to me about the ways that
you've
worked through some of your trauma has
given me
the opportunity to think about
alternatives that might also help me
and things that i've never considered
before that i'm now considering
hmm and uh on that point
i am talking to two different people
uh twice a week right now that's right
so i so i am
using i am using that tool in the tool
kit
and that's in no small measure
due to you thank you and uh
and i would also say that
uh now a lot of what we've said alluded
to this i think but
another key takeaway for me or just a
mantra perhaps that i
try to remind myself of that might be
helpful
to people listening is you know how can
you use your suffering to
connect with people rather than isolate
yourself from people
how can you use your suffering this is
this is the water in which we all swim
how can you use your suffering to better
connect to others
rather than isolate yourself it is
possible
and of course i'll i'll include all the
resources that we've talked about and
i'm sure it'll be a growing list
on the blog in the show notes so i'll
just mention two things
tim dot blog forward slash podcast for
this podcast assuming it gets released
and tim.blog forward slash trauma
and i'll make that a a live
resource that will no doubt change over
time so debbie
you're a lovely lovely human being and i
so appreciate you
and i just want to extend my
my love and sincerest thanks for being
so patient with me as i hemmed
and hawed and postponed
for so long before this conversation
it's all good i love you dearly
dearly i feel like we're brother and
sister yeah i love you too debbie
and uh to everybody out there one more
time
you're never alone it's never hopeless
there are tools
and until next time thanks for listening